bienvenue à Istanbul
oh c'est beau c'est le meilleur oui il
est là je veux maintenant la lumière
écoute moi attentivement cadeau mère et je
vais être pris qu'est ce que tu vas faire
sont ceux que tu as le mieux tiré ces
pierres Jason c'est très très élaboré
toi  're le réalisateur apporte vraiment
un cran sur ce front aussi
j'ai lu essayez d'être plus créatif sur celui-
ci tous mes angles sont dans votre titre les
cascades sont incroyables et les
séquences d'action dans les poursuites en voiture
je n'ai jamais tiré sur une voiture  -chassez de cette façon
avant que ce ne soit vraiment cool, vous savez que la
caméra peut être à l'intérieur de la voiture ou olivier
a un petit tabouret pivotant qui se
fixe du côté passager, vous avez l'impression
d'être dans la voiture des caméras plus petites
et les caméras GoPro sont tout simplement géniales
parce que vous pouvez les mettre partout
et vous pouvez vraiment capturer une grande
action
vous savez en tant que cascadeur parfois
vous tombez et vous voyez
quelque chose de vos yeux non j'aurais aimé que ce
soit dans le film et maintenant vous pouvez capturer
c'est moi  t garde vraiment les éléments qui ont
fonctionné sur le premier ils ne se
battent pas seulement pour survivre ils se
battent vraiment les uns pour les autres et donc nous avons
cette famille à enraciner car ce n'est pas un
jeu